el acceso al aborto en Estados Unidos
sigue generando debate y batallas
jurídicas el tribunal supremo de ese
país amplió temporalmente hasta el
viernes una orden para mantener la
píldora abortiva mifepristona
ampliamente disponible con el fin de dar
más tiempo a los jueces para estudiar la
sentencia de un tribunal inferior que
impuso restricciones al acceso a la
medicación la mifepristona el método más
común de interrupción del embarazo en el
país se comercializa en Estados Unidos
desde el año 2000 la semana pasada un
juez de Texas declaró que el fármaco
había sido aprobado indebidamente
suspendiendo la aprobación de la
administración de medicamentos y
alimentos o fda por sus siglas en inglés
y aunque un tribunal Federal bloqueó
parcialmente la sentencia impuso
restricciones que fueron rechazadas por
el gobierno haciendo que el caso
terminara en el supremo la
administración del presidente biden se
ha comprometido a proteger los derechos
reproductivos de las mujeres frente a la
crecientes prohibiciones del aborto
estamos preparados para cualquier
resultado que pueda emitir el tribunal
supremo y estamos preparados para una
larga lucha legal si es necesario lo que
está en juego no podría ser mayor y
vamos a seguir luchando
el tribunal supremo es mayoritariamente
masculino con una mayoría conservadora
de seis tres y desde que se revocó la
sentencia
el pasado mes de junio el aborto ya no
es un derecho protegido por la
Constitución de Estados Unidos y 13
estados han implantado prohibiciones un
juez de Texas se pronuncia a favor de la
prohibición total de la mifepristona y
el próximo viernes el tribunal supremo
podría anular su sentencia u optar por
restringir su prescripción y
distribución el fármaco está ampliamente
considerado como el método de aborto más
seguro y eficaz en las primeras 10
semanas de embarazo y se ha utilizado
para interrumpir unas 5,6 millones de
gestaciones en Estados Unidos